muy buenos días soy gabriela correa y
soy cuentacuentos
esperaba que me contestarán o la
gabriela y entonces yo sabría que estoy
en una reunión de cuentacuentos anónimos
y que extraño porque yo creo que todas y
todos contamos o por lo menos nos
contamos a nosotros mismos hace unas
semanas cuando me dirigía precisamente a
un ensayo de ted en el centro me topé
con una chica de escasos 16 18 años y
muy cerquita de ella un hombre muy mayor
y evidentemente alcoholizado
sin pensarlo sin reflexionar nada cuando
él se le acercó de más de lo que yo
estaba pensando me dirigía hacia ella y
le dije te está molestando
ella volteó a verme con una sonrisa
desencajada y me dijo no es mi papá
inmediatamente se me vino como balde de
agua fría los recuerdos las imágenes de
una historia y me pregunte qué sería de
mí si yo no me hubiera contado esa
historia de manera diferente donde
estaría yo ahora si mi madre no hubiese
contado esas anécdotas a la mitad de una
carcajada
cuando yo narro para un colectivo de
niñas y niños yo les platico que cuando
yo era pequeña era muy pero muy pero muy
chismosa y si la verdad lo que más
disfrutaba era hablar me encantaba
compartir todo lo que yo escuchaba lo
que veía pero sobre todo lo que sentía y
si aquí se encuentran maestros y
maestros frente a grupo
sabrán perfectamente de lo que les habla
seguro sus días están aderezados de las
conversaciones de sus alumnos desde la
última discusión de sus padres hasta lo
que comieron el día anterior
o lo que vieron en la televisión o lo
que escucharon de lo que está pasando en
el mundo de la violencia de la
delincuencia de la destrucción del
planeta
y justo por esa razón es que elegí esta
charla para compartir con ustedes porque
me volvía a preguntar
qué tal que todas esas niñas y niños
pueden contar su historia de una manera
diferente
qué pasaría si cada uno de esos seres
pudiera narrar se a partir del perfil de
la felicidad
y lo más importante
cómo puedo contribuir yo
a que esas historias se cuenten de otra
forma
cuando yo descubrí el mundo de la
literatura infantil y la lectura en voz
alta me topé de frente con el acto más
sencillo y generoso de compartir amor
recuerdo perfecto una ocasión en que
narre la familia de los cerdos de
anthony brawn un niño al fondo estiraba
el brazo exclusivamente cuando había
terminado y cuando le dimos la palabra
me dijo
ahora yo ya le voy a ayudar a mi mamá en
la casa porque así como la señora del
cuento ella es la que hace todo ella
solita
o como aquella vez que una interna del
cereso femenil me devolvía un libro
infantil que le había prestado y me dijo
muchas gracias sabe yo me sentía como la
del cuento muñeca rota que hablaba sobre
la vida de frida kahlo yo me sentía rota
por dentro
no tengo idea si ese libro la re compuso
internamente sin embargo estoy segura
que el hecho de saber que alguien más se
sentía como ella
le ayudo al corazón
muy probablemente todos recordemos a una
maestra o maestro que nos leyó por el
puro placer de leer sin pedirnos después
un cuestionario o un resumen o nada o
incluso a lo mejor alguien que nos
contaba alguna anécdota de la escuela de
su vida personal
todos recordaremos quizá algún texto que
se nos quedó aquí por el simple hecho de
que alguien más nos lo leyó
y me pregunto otra vez si eso hizo un
solo cuento
qué haría en la vida de estas niñas y
niños
un cuento diario un cuento regalado un
cuento por el puro gozo de regalar y de
escuchar dice gianni rodari el acceso
absoluto a la lectura y escritura para
todas las personas no para que todos
seamos artistas sino para que nadie sea
esclavo
cuando escuchar a cada una de mis
compañeras y compañeros que me
precedieron venían a mi mente en cada
charla un libro infantil la sombra de
julia muñeca rota harta del rosa a mí no
me gusta el fútbol y qué
cada uno de esos adaptado
específicamente a la charla ya la
historia de cada uno de ellos
así que dejo una pregunta en el aire
qué se necesita
para que yo contribuya para que estos
niños y niñas que mañana jóvenes o
adultos puedan compartir a su vez
había una vez
alguien que me leyó
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]